hallo liebe zuschauer und schön dass ihr
wieder eingeschaltet habt heute zu einer
neuen folge von kari antwortet ich
beantworte heute wieder fragen von euch
und los geht's mit frage 1 robert morris
mehr hat uns geschrieben
hey kannst du uns erklären wie das
politische panorama ist abgesehen von
merkel gibt es etwas anderes
gute frage linkspartei grüne partei
danke ja natürlich gibt es etwas anderes
außer angela merkel auch wenn man ist
glauben kaum glauben mag denn
tatsächlich ist angela merkel quasi
omnipräsent
sie ist seit zehn jahren bundeskanzlerin
und wenn sie sogar bei der nächsten wahl
bei der bundestagswahl 2017 gewinnt kann
es sogar sein dass sie zu den längsten
regierenden bundeskanzlern
bundeskanzlerin der bundesrepublik
deutschland zählt denn dann wäre sie
insgesamt 16 jahre im amt
nichtsdestotrotz gibt es aber natürlich
andere parteien und auch partei die
relativ stark sind wenn man ausländern
kommt wo es quasi nur ein zwei parteien
system gibt dann mag es überraschen dass
ist in deutschland relativ viele
parteien gibt ich zeige euch mal so die
größten parteien die stärkste partei im
moment ist die cdu das ist die
tatsächlich die partei von angela merkel
die christlich demokratische union
deutschlands
die werden so ein bisschen als ja
konservative partei in deutschland
gesehen
die zweitgrößte partei ist die spd und
ganz klassischer weise sind cdu und spd
immer in einem konkurrenzkampf
zueinander allerdings in der aktuellen
zeit gibt es eine koalition das heißt
cdu und spd regiert zusammen
die spd sind auch ist werden auch die
sozialdemokraten genannt und sie sind
klassischerweise eher für die
arbeitnehmerrechte zuständig und kümmern
sich um die belange des kleinen mannes
dann gibt es noch drei kleinere parteien
die auch traditionell verwurzelt sind in
deutschland das ist einmal die fdp die
liberalen die grünen die wie der name
schon sagt sich vor allem der umwelt
wegen der umweltpolitik wegen gegründet
haben und die linke wie der name schon
sagt eine linke partei
da ich jetzt natürlich nicht die ganze
geschichte dieser parteien erklären kann
werde ich dem einen link unten in die
infobox stellen wo du etwas mehr lesen
kannst über die geschichte der
politischen parteien in deutschland
was interessant ist zu wissen für
jemanden der aus dem ausland kommt in
deutschland gibt es ein relativ stabiles
politisches system würde ich sagen das
heißt bei den wahlen gibt es nicht immer
allzu große veränderungen
die deutschen mögen veränderungen nicht
unbedingt so könnte man es sagen gerade
nach unserer geschichte nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg hat sich das eigentlich das
politische system sehr stabilisiert
deutsche mögen generell auch nicht
parteien oder politische führer die
plötzlich aus dem nichts kommen und
plötzlich bekannt sind
das heißt viele neue parteien es gibt
zwar immer neue parteien aber sie
bekommen nicht ganz plötzlich ganz viele
stimmen wie das in manchen anderen
männern ist und ja generell kann man
schon eher sagen dass politische
parteien system in deutschland ist er
stabil die parteien nehmen sich nicht so
ganz viel
es ändert sich nicht so ganz vielen mal
regiert der eine mit dem anderen mal der
andere mit dem einen seo moog im
schreibt danke für das video er meint es
von der letzten woche was mir sehr leid
tut ist dass sehr viele leute hier in
südkorea davor angst haben die
flüchtlinge neuankömmlinge oder sogar
die leute aufzunehmen die muslime sind
weil man hier das vorurteil hat wiegen
was sie in der vergangenheit gemacht
haben manche muslime waren terroristen
ehrlich gesagt ich persönlich habe auch
solche angst wie die anderen in südkorea
aber ich will keine muslime beleidigen
oder verallgemeinern dass sie alle böse
terroristen sind ja damit hast du schon
etwas sehr gutes gesagt und wir alle
müssen natürlich aufpassen dass wir
nicht mit vorurteilen aber gerade in
dieser zeit sind vorteile leider einer
eines der größten probleme was wir haben
wenn du zum beispiel sachs oder wenn man
in korea denkt dass alle muslime
terroristen sind kann man umgekehrt auch
sagen was ist wenn alle leute in europa
denken dass alle koreaner wie kim
jong-un sind das ist nur ein beispiel
und das paradox ist ja gerade an
vorurteilen dass menschen mit menschen
verwechselt werden mit denen sie gar
nichts zu tun haben wollen zum beispiel
wenn man sagt alle deutschen sind wie
nazis weil vielleicht an einem anderen
ende der welt das einzige was man von
deutschland gehört hat ist die nazizeit
wir alle sollten aufpassen dass wir uns
bei sowas immer zwei mal gucken denn es
gibt immer mehr als eine gruppe es gibt
auch immer mehr als zwei gruppen
meistens gibt es sogar ein sehr viel
diverse riss bild wenn wir alle genauer
hin kommen und dass gerade das mikrofon
runtergefallen schaut genauer hin wenn
ihr euch über eine gruppe äußert
eigentlich ist es generell nie gut zu
sagen die sind so und die sind so
gruppen sind immer unterschiedlich
romulus wayne los silos schreibt die
arme nie los sagt die germany germany
antwortet die rollos ja er wirkte
germany der nation stephan ruers links
in der history at the same time heft
komplett lässt wenn your country in the
first dance day at the very proud euro -
das stimmt viele nationen sind
tatsächlich unglaublich stolz auf ihr
land
und wir deutschen sind es ein bisschen
weniger das liegt natürlich auch an
unserer geschichte es ist aber nicht so
dass wir da besonders darum trauern
viele von euch denken ja oft wir
deutschen wir sind eigentlich so stolz
auf unser land aber wir dürfen es nicht
sagen wegen der geschichte so ist das
gar nicht wir deutschen sind schon sehr
glücklich dass wir hier leben und ich
würde sagen dass die meisten sich sehr
positiv mit ihrem land identifizieren
sehr gerne in deutschland leben und auch
sehr zu schätzen wissen was sie haben
aber stolz ist eben etwas anderes stolz
ist für uns in
ein gefühl so etwas ein bisschen
übertriebenes stolz ist jemand der
irgendwie selber nicht hat und sich dann
daran irgendwie besonders toll fühlt
wenn er jetzt auf etwas stolz ist zu dem
man gar nichts beigetragen hat so
empfinde ich das oft so nationalstolz so
richtiger nationalstolz hat das jemals
zu etwas gutem geführt nächster als big
bopper schreibt greenpeace street once
around but the wait for some reason
habig verbracht was haben wir schon mal
thematisiert bei uns das ist typisch
deutsch
die deutschen sind sehr ordnungsliebend
mein mann janisch zum beispiel der kommt
aus polen und der hass dass auch wie die
pest und ich muss sagen ich hatte das
auch ein bisschen aber so ganz kann ich
mich nicht dagegen wehren wenn wir
irgendwo eine regel haben oder eine
vorschrift dann haben wir deutschen so
traditionell immer ein bisschen angst
die ordnung zu brechen das ist sehr
witzig wenn man nach deutschland kommt
sieht man tatsächlich ein paar verrückte
dinge und menschen die nachts um 2 uhr
an der ampel stehen und sich nicht
trauen weil rot rüber zu gehen obwohl
kein mensch
um sie herum ist das ist auch etwas was
sehr typisch leute ist zum thema freunde
finden erinnert euch an die episode wie
finde ich freunde in deutschland
schreibt isabel germans are really
distanz people with complicated
mentality money for owners have to have
this opening the experience the same
distance germans claim to be open minded
stop it stop it schreibt isabel ja was
sagt man dazu da sag ich da hat wohl
jemand schlechte erfahrungen in
deutschland gemacht das tut mir
natürlich leid dieser welt
aber du musst immer essen es gibt ja
solche und solche es gibt solche
deutschland solche deutsche es gibt auch
solche englisch
solche engländer nicht alle deutschen
sind so manche sind so die sind ein
bisschen zurückhaltender das muss man
leider wissen wenn man aus einem anderen
land kommt
aber nicht alle sind so und etwas
ähnliches schreibt lost destiny er oder
sie schreibt ein jahr in deutschland und
gar keinen freund gefunden das ist ein
zitat aus von einem anderen zuschauer
das klingt ja nach mir es ist schon
komisch wie distanziert manche leute an
der uni sind die klicken in meiner uni
gruppe scheinen sich vorher gekannt zu
haben
da kann man sich etwas ausgegrenzt
fühlen diese problematik als
ausländischer student kann ich nur
bestätigen in ostdeutschland zu
studieren macht ist ja noch schwerer da
es weniger ausländische studierende gibt
die deine sorgen nachvollziehen können
ja los destiny auch dieses thema haben
wir schon oft thematisiert und das tut
mir natürlich leid dass du solche
erfahrungen machen muss ist an einer uni
aber ich kann nur immer wieder sagen
nicht aufgeben nicht aufgeben deutsche
sind reservierter und sind distanzierter
als andere menschen wir erleben dass
jeden tag manchmal gehen wir auf die
straße mit dem mikrofone wir wollen eine
frage stellen und zehn leute
nacheinander sagen nein
und wenn wir an diesem zeitpunkt nach
hause gehen würden würde es gar kein
zusammengehen und deswegen darfst du
nicht aufgeben geht einfach weiter such
dir ein paar nette leute sucht dir
hobbys versuch es weiter du wirst schon
leute finden denn es gibt auch in
deutschland sehr viele nette leute
letzter kommentar für heute kommt von
mtv german speaker voll englisch ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha schreibt mtv
dass das stimmt viele deutsche sprechen
schrecklich englisch aber bitte bitte
ihr dürft solche kommentare nicht machen
weil deutsche haben so ein bisschen
paranoia darüber englisch zu sprechen
viele leute die ich kenne ja meine
generation und auch die meisten
generationen davor und danach
die lernen acht oder neun jahre englisch
in der schule und ganz viele haben
trotzdem angst englisch zu sprechen und
wenn sie jemand anspricht oder wenn sie
eine internationalen in eine runde
kommen wo ein ausländer dabei ist und
man muss englisch sprechen kannst ganz
viele so ängstlich und wissen nicht sie
haben einfach angst fehler zu machen
weil deutsche die machen sich auch
lustig über andere deutsche die schlecht
englisch sprechen und das ist dumm wenn
man eine sprache lernt soll man sie
probieren wenn ihr deutschland sollte
auch probieren durchzusprechen
scheißegal auf ihr fehler macht oder
nicht
also bitte lasst die deutschen mit ihrem
schlechten englisch lasst sie doch
einfach in ruhe version
denn wer die zeit im moment eben more
than two million people watchers online
und wie all die all-in-one germany ja
liebe leute das war's auch schon für
diese woche bei kali antwortet bitte
schickt uns mehr fragen alle möglichen
fragen lustige fragen ernste fragen
traurige fragen komische fragen fragen
die ihr euch nicht traut zu stellen
schickt sie bitte an mich denn ich freue
mich über jede frage schreibt sie hier
unten in die kommentare alles zu
deutschland zur deutschen sprache wo ihr
probleme habt und jetzt zum schluss noch
mal ein herzliches danke an johnny
murphy johnny du bist einer der menschen
die über batterien mit deinem support
unsere arbeit möglich machen dafür
möchten wir heute danke an dich sagen
grüß dich johnny und grüße an alle
anderen von euch schickt uns kommentare
unbedingt kommentare tschüss und bis zur
nächsten woche
kommentare mehr kommentare kommentar
antworten gibt uns fragen